So here we are, about halfway through the science unit.
I want to stop for a minute and just sort of get an idea with how you guys are doing.
I want you to take a minute and just think about a couple of things.
One, how are your relationships doing?
We've talked since the beginning about forming good relationships and creating a culture
where questions are welcome and students are being honest with you and with one
another and that their faith is developing.
So kind of take a step back and take some time this week and analyze how that's going.
Are your relationships furthering?
Are they getting better?
Are new students coming in?
How are they assimilating those types of things?
The second thing is how are students tracking?
Now let's be honest.
This is not easy.
So ask yourself and sort of maybe even ask some of your students, how are they tracking?
Is it all making sense that they just kind of nod in their head like they kind of get
it but then in the back of their mind they're going, I don't get it?
Or are they like just super fired up and they're digging for more and they're asking great
questions or are you like everywhere in between?
It's very possible.
It could be all over the spectrum.
But take a second, stop and think about where your students are, which leads then
to asking yourself, do I need to slow it down?
Do I need to maybe adapt things a little bit?
Don't be afraid to pull back, revisit some concepts.
Make sure there's understanding, go back and ask some questions, figure out and make
sure that your students are exactly where you need them to be so that you can move
forward successfully.
Don't move forward until you are certain that your students are ready to do so.
So as you and your students are navigating some of these difficult waters, I want you
to keep in mind two really important things.
The first is the misconceptions that we've provided.
These misconceptions are a clear window into the world of what your students are
actually being taught.
Now they may not be taught these exact quotes or reading these exact things, but the
stuff that we're quoting, the stuff that we're citing are the underlying narrative
that your students are reading about in textbooks in school.
The second thing is the examples that you use.
It's so important if you can use the right kind of examples to simplify some of these
difficult concepts to make it a little bit easier to understand.
And the best example really is Sean's use of just simply describing a book to help
us understand DNA.